on May 16 2013 the first day of Google
i/o Hugo Berra of Google kind of
surprised the world he pulled a samsung
galaxy s4 out of his pocket on a stage
where you only expect to hear and even
mention a Google Nexus device and not
only did he hold one up and talk about
it but he revealed that the one he was
holding was a special one it wasn't
running the typical Samsung's TouchWiz
skin on top of Android at all it's gaudy
animations and colors and features his
Galaxy s4 was running a Google version
of Android it had a nexus experience as
he put it in Google's clean lines and
blue hollow accents and everything this
Galaxy s4 was really special he called
it the Google Play edition but not only
was he holding a Google Play edition
galaxy s4 and not only was it a project
that came together in the last week but
he also announced that it would go on
sale later that month in the Google Play
Store and it did and an HTC One Google
Play edition appeared alongside it but
then there was nothing there was silence
month after month of silence about the
whole Google Play edition thing until
last week where we got two new Google
Play edition phones so we now have
actually a tablet in there the LG G pad
8.3 Google Play edition and the Sony
Xperia Z ultra Google Play edition so
that's two new OEMs and two new screen
sizes we have LG on board now and we
have Sony on board now we have an eight
point three inch display and a 6 point 4
inch display in the mix so after all
this weight it turns out Google is
continuing to work with OMS or original
equipment manufacturers to continue to
make these Google Play edition devices
with the pure almost Nexus like
experience and the really fast software
updates but the question is why why does
Google keep doing this and why do OMS
keep working with Google to do this
wouldn't these be seen as competition to
the non Google Play edition versions of
these phones if I was Samsung and I was
spending my millions and millions of
dollars on marketing and advertising for
my new Galaxy s4 what sort of incentive
would I ever have to work on the side
project with Google on an alternate
edition to sell in a different store
wouldn't that sort of compete with the
sales of our original goal well the
truth is the Google Play edition doesn't
sell like at all it has very very low
sales numbers and as proof
that how many iPhones do you see in the
wild how many regular Galaxy s4 is do
you see in the wild and then how many
Google Play edition devices do you see
people using out there probably almost
zero if not not at all and on top of
that Google Play editions get zero
advertising you have not and likely
never will see an advertisement for a
Google Play edition device from Google
or from any of the OEMs who are busy
selling their standard editions and so
it's become very clear that Google just
does not care about the sales numbers of
Google Play edition devices they're not
supposed to sell millions instead
consider that the Google Play edition
might actually be strangely named a
better name might be a the premium
developer edition because these devices
are perfect for developers they come
with the latest version of Android and
get updated very quickly so you can
develop on the latest that Google has to
offer and they ship with unlocked boot
loaders which to put simply is way more
developer-friendly fragmentation is a
word that's thrown around a lot and in a
couple of cases an Android app that's
developed on and tested for one Android
phone will literally not work with
another Android phone whether that's
because of a difference in screen size
or resolution or SOC or graphics or any
combination of those things so there's a
chance a very small chance that giving
developers more hardware options to
develop on will make it easier to
develop for more hardware options
there's a chance that a developer with a
Google Play edition LG G pad 8.3 will
develop his app to work perfectly on
that hardware the eight point three inch
display the 1080p resolution the
Snapdragon 600 SOC the audrina 320 GPU
all that stuff in theory this would
translate to a tiny advantage for LG
because now there is a couple more apps
in the Play Store that are going to work
perfectly with the LG G pad 8.3 or at
least be well compatible but that's just
a theory basically don't read too much
into the last part essentially it's only
two more Google Play edition devices
it's not a huge deal but just the fact
that there are anymore Google Play
edition devices means that Google hasn't
forgotten about it and that Google still
thinks that this is the right way to
keep developers happy and that this is a
good thing to continue to do to work
with these OEMs and make these devices
and it also happens to have the great
upside that geeks like me and possibly
you love using so that
is the google play edition devices
explained but honestly in a dream world
we have every device as a Google Play
edition right what would you want to see
as a Google Play edition phone or tablet
now there's a more realistic and then
less realistic choices I think more
realistic and desirable would be a
Google Play edition LG g2 maybe a Google
Play edition galaxy note 3 that would be
nice but then those of course the
far-fetched no reason to ever happen
Google Play edition Lumia 1020 Google
Play edition iPhone iPad whatever let me
know what you guys would love to have a
Google Play edition of in the comment
section below
bonus points if you tell me how many
times I said Google Play edition in this
video it's probably a lot either way
that's it thank you for watching this
video if you want to hit that thumbs up
button below that would be awesome but
more importantly there's a subscribe
button if you want to see more videos
like this on a regular basis thank you
for watching and I will talk to you guys
in the next one peace
you